i've been watching miyazaki films
because you commented on spirited away
and i wanted to watch it again so i
started watching a few
and i was trying to put my finger on why
is it so it's
it's damn good his films are very good
and i realized not only is are they
magical and whimsical like a child and
an
imaginative but there's a complete lack
of cynicism
yeah a complete lack of sarcasm sarcasm
or or sardonic commentary yeah no that's
i think you really put your finger on it
and i think that because we're in a
situation
because of our because of technology and
because of
our extremely ordered societies where we
have a
you know everything is controlled by the
state basically not everything but
so much of our world is controlled by
the state and by these giant
corporations and everything
we have a need for feminine symbolism
we have a need for the private sphere we
have a need for
the refreshing aspect of of our personal
relationships all this feminine
symbolism
we have a desire and a need for it and
the thing about miyazaki is that
almost all his films take on this
feminine symbolism but he does it in
such a beautiful
way where he doesn't feel the need to be
subversive or to kind of show how you
know the male character is an idiot or
or or yeah there's useless there's a
complete absence or lack
of a political message oh yeah no i
think the closest maybe
ponyo where he says the humans are
ruining the earth right with their ships
that's the closest
that i've found so far but i agree i
agree that that's what makes him so
strong and that's why and they make him
so strong also because he's able
to create strong female characters but
in a manner which is not
doesn't it doesn't have that kind of
anger and bitterness and cynicism in it
where it's more like a celebration of
of these beautiful feminine characters
and it doesn't make the feminine the
masculine
it doesn't make a girl have
traditionally masculine qualities and
then say
we're subverting notions of gender yeah
because that's what i mean that's what
so many of the the like the superhero
moves that we've seen recently and
a lot of the like the star wars movies
and everything is and i think that's why
people are
kind of annoyed with them is because
they're
it's not only the desire to make let's
say a
feminine care a female character into
the same action hero
that we've had you know since the 1980s
that everybody's criticized
like it's you know it's the feminist or
you know the the postmodern criticized
that figure of the
of this of the hero of the male hero and
so but now you want to make a woman into
it
masculinity is toxic as long as it's a
male exactly
like masculinity becomes good if it's a
female who embodies it
it's just completely it's completely
upside down i mean here's what else what
else does i find funny about that
then feminist femininity is just
unattractive when it's attached to a
male so as a male you can't win
it's very difficult if you're if you're
a masculine so but if you're attractive
and you're
toxic and you have toxic masculinity you
can get away with almost anything yeah
we had had this conversation with janice
fiamango that the people who are getting
who are getting sent letters saying stop
what you're doing
is are they tend to be people who are
unattractive yeah males
yeah exactly if you were an attractive
male then the woman wouldn't find it
catcalling she would find it no i
totally agree
who's that who's the british comedian
there that jordan did an interview with
i forget his name
the this one british comedian
he's milo no no he's he jordan jordan
did a
i think he was like he was like a huge
deal and he he came to press and
everything
he did an interview with sam harris and
he did interview with jordan he's kind
of on board with intel intellectual dark
anyways he was like
he was this super good looking guy and
he was extremely promiscuous you know
and just had loads and loads of sex all
kinds of women and i saw
russell brown yeah russell brent i saw
him once meeting with a woman
talking to her and he reached back
behind her back and he undid her bra
like
that and oh and everybody was laughing
and she was laughing and she's like oh
what did you do it's so funny
and like really interesting you know
imagine if anybody else had done that
you know what it would have been and i'm
just i mean i i'm figuring like maybe
russell ren at some point you're going
to turn on him when he kind
of when he loses his his attractive edge
they might turn on him at some point
but uh yeah and i agree that it's mostly
that that
certain behaviors uh let's say trying to
trying to be
flirty with a woman if you're
good-looking and you're into your
desirable then that's not a problem but
if you're ugly